what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder i'm your host
warren thompson and today we have a lot
of exciting news to talk about that i
think fans are going to be really really
happy to hear about the future of the
mcu today we'll be talking about a
spider-man and daredevil team-up in the
mcu that was teased by marvel studios as
president kevin feige himself he also
talked about how secret wars is going to
be bigger than avengers in-game and
infinity war but also how they are going
to be different and how kang is going to
be different than thanos and how we're
going to get big team-up films before
the avengers films come out and this
could include ant-man and the wasp
quantum mania looks like ant-man 3 is
going to be a big semi-avengers team-up
film and could possibly even introduce
the fantastic four or the young avengers
and to top it all off kevin feige has
actually came out and defined the
different areas of the mcu like we have
been talking about for a very long time
so like i said lots of exciting things
to talk about so if you're new be sure
to subscribe so you don't miss out on
any of the latest mcu news now the first
thing that we have to talk about because
it is just so exciting is spider-man and
daredevil it looks like they are finally
going to be teaming up in the mcu i'm
sure most everybody is aware but if you
are not at san diego comic con marvel
studios announced that they are indeed
rebooting daredevil and charlie cox is
coming back of course to play matt
murdock and kingpin is of course going
to be played by the one and only vincent
d'onofrio that's right the original
daredevil and the original kingpin from
the netflix series are coming to the mcu
now as far as the continuity between the
netflix world and the mcu it's still a
little bit unclear we don't know if
these are the exact same characters from
that exact same world based off of
everything that we've heard so far they
kind of are the same except the stories
are going to just be changed a little
bit now it is called daredevil born
again and while this could be a nod to
the fact that they are kind of rebooting
the character from the netflix series
and he's going to be new in the mcu it
is also a marvel comics graphic novel
written by frank miller now in the
comics the daredevil born again story
arc is kind of about daredevil becoming
insane and struggling to build a new
life for himself and we'll see this in
18 different episodes and that's really
exciting on its own but if you consider
the fact that spider-man might actually
show up in the series it gets even more
exciting and of course daredevil could
show up in the spider-man films as well
now here's what kevin feige recently had
to say after san diego comic-con when
speaking to mtv and as you start to see
you talk about ghost rider we've got
blade we've got dr stranger at the
supernatural right angles we've got the
street level with our announcement of
daredevil and of course spidey going
into the street level uh heroes and
cosmic and that's where where our
friends arrows and pip live so here
kevin feige was describing the different
sides of the mcu then he says we have
daredevil going into the street level
and then spidey is going into the street
level as well this is a huge hint that
spider-man and daredevil are going to
team up in the future which makes
perfect sense this happens plenty of
time in the comics and everybody pretty
much loves it also not to mention
kingpin is about to be in the mcu and
daredevil born again kingpin is a major
spider-man villain of course along with
daredevil but i think everybody assumes
that now it is only a matter of time
until spider-man runs into kingpin and
since daredevil is going to be dealing
with kingpin first it looks like a team
up is definitely in our future hopefully
very soon now in the same interview
kevin feige has actually teased that we
are going to start to see a lot more
team ups before our big avengers films
take a look here
and certainly after infinity war and end
game that we thought avengers movies
aren't cappers so many of our movies now
the multiverse of madness what you're
about to see in quantum mania are big
team-up films introducing big parts of
the mythology and that avengers films
really should be the capper to a saga
which is really all we wanted to to lay
the groundwork for today is say we are
currently in the midst of the multiverse
saga which will culminate uh in two
avengers films so he teases other
team-up films like we got in doctor
strange in the multiverse of madness and
then he says like we're about to see in
ant-man 3. so more than just ant-man and
the wasp and this actually makes sense
because it's been revealed that modoc is
going to be a villain of ant-man 3 as
well along with kang so who is going to
be joining ant-man and the wasp in
ant-man 3. let's talk about this but
first big thank you to athletic greens
for sponsoring this video if you are
trying to be more healthy if you're
trying to support your immune health if
you're looking to have more energy and
you're tired of taking all of those
pills athletic greens is for you i
wanted to see what all of the hype was
about so i tried athletic greens it
gives you over 75 high quality vitamins
minerals adaptogens and probiotics now
this is lifestyle friendly so you can
take this whether you're doing paleo
keto vegan dairy-free gluten-free you
can still take this and it's less than
three dollars a day which is pretty
cheap considering you're investing in
your health and the best part is it
actually tastes pretty dang good so if
you're looking to get healthier and toss
out the pills and the supplements
athletic greens makes it easy they're
going to give you a free one year supply
of immune supporting vitamin d and 5
free travel packs with your first
purchase all you have to do is visit
athleticgreens.com
cosmic again that is athleticgreens.com
cosmic take ownership over your health
and pick up the ultimate daily
nutritional insurance now who could be
joining ant-man well rumors have been
going around for a while that marvel
studios might introduce the fantastic
four in ant-man 3. kevin feige has just
recently revealed that the fantastic
four movie is not going to be a typical
origin story could the fact that the new
fantastic four film isn't going to be an
origin story be due to the fact that we
could be seeing the fantastic four
earlier on in the mcu with ant-man 3
really exploring the quantum realm and
perhaps the fantastic four maybe even
getting their powers from the quantum
realm in the mcu that is it may be that
the fantastic four could actually be the
ones teaming up with ant-man to go
against king the conqueror and modoc
after all the team of the fantastic four
are scientists and they could very well
be working with hank pym to study the
quantum realm the fantastic four have
spent plenty of time in the negative
zone in the comics and the mcu could be
viewing the quantum realm as sort of
another negative zone as well so there
is a possibility that the fantastic four
could show up and team up with ant-man
the wasp and everybody else in ant-man
3. now of course the other possibility
which kind of seems likely at this point
is a team up with some young avengers
now we already know that scott lang's
daughter cassie lange is going to be
stature she is about to be a hero in the
mcu and they've already actually teased
her in the very first poster that we got
for ant-man 3 during sdcc and this might
actually be the team up just scott lang
with the wasp and his daughter stature
and of course i'm assuming hank pym and
janet van dime are a part of the team as
well because keep in mind doctor strange
and the multiverse of madness was a
team-up film according to kevin feige
and it was but it really only involved
one team and then one other person the
team of the sorcerers and america chavez
and then the scarlet witch and it really
wasn't a team up they were enemies so
the team up might not be that big i
would love for the fantastic four to be
in ant-man 3 but i'm assuming it's going
to set up the young avengers with
stature and probably one or a couple of
more young avengers now the good news is
is that kevin feige has essentially
confirmed that secret wars is going to
be bigger than avengers infinity war and
end game he said that we are going to
have these team-up films that lead up to
these huge avengers films that will
always end a saga so we're not going to
have a new avengers film every couple of
years now every few years we're only
going to have really big avengers films
that end sagas entirely and that's why
kevin feige is saying that we're going
to have all these other kind of mini
avengers films where we see a bunch of
heroes team up before avengers movies
but kevin feige confirmed in an
interview that due to the sheer fact
that we now have all of these disney
plush shows and are able to introduce a
lot more new characters per year the new
avengers movies the kang dynasty and
secret wars are going to naturally be
bigger than avengers infinity war and in
game because there are a lot more
characters and in-game had a lot of
characters but secret wars is also going
to have variants so as we all know there
are going to be a ton of heroes and some
of the same heroes just different
variants in one film but before we get
to that kevin feige has defined the
areas of the mcu i have actually been
talking about this for a pretty long
time i have described the supernatural
side the earthly side and the cosmic
side and for the most part i was right
except kevin feige calls the earthly
side the street side he has said that we
have the supernatural side the street
side and then the cosmic side and when
he mentioned the supernatural side he
even mentioned ghost rider and with that
big tease of donnie blaze not johnny
blaze but donny blaze and the new
she-hulk trailer it does seem like ghost
rider is upon us hopefully pretty soon
but in the meantime it looks like the
mcu is going to have plenty of exciting
projects let me know what you're most
excited for in the comments down below
don't forget to like the video and
subscribe to stay up to date on all
things mcu for live updates you can
follow me on instagram and twitter and
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof
you